Oh
Hey Casey, good news! Oh Elsa, I don't care. Why are you calling mom
Elsa? Your Clayton uniform came today, It is adorable.
It just looks smart.
What you think of the roast? I tried a new prepackaged spice mix
(gasp)cheater
For most mammalian species survival depends on knowing and sticking with your pack. Stop sitting on me like an egg! I'm not an egg.
cheep cheep cheep cheep
But the members of my pack keep migrating to other schools, I hate it there just give it a chance
Hey, I'm Casey. Don't care two other houses you threw a grenade into our lives
I can't be around you or just away from me
It's a mystery what was once something that seems so rock solid it cracks wide open?
Before you know it you are so deep. It's impossible to dig yourself back out if anyone find it difficult to deal with change
But there's always a way out
I know it's gonna be difficult, but you can handle it
He hasn't applied to any colleges. I have no idea what I should do. You have to start making decisions for yourself
What do you want to do?
Everybody has setbacks. Oh
You can't let em bring you down. Would it be this out? Okay
I used my discount to get you these pencils for school. You don't have to do that
I'll be a big brother. I can take care of you sometimes too
we must look like terrible parents
eh you seem like people
It's a rough world out there, that's why you need your family
I like that we're secure enough to do this. Semi-regularly. I'm neutral about it
You